franz almer ich will dich mit ins
gespräch
reinziehen du warst heute den ganzen tag
unterwegs an der front und wir wollen
uns zunächst anschauen was du dort für
eindrücke mitgebracht hast also aus der
ost ukraine
es ist sonntagmorgen bild reporter paul
ronzheimer unterwegs in der ost ukraine
dort an der front spricht er gerade mit
ukrainischen soldaten über eine
russische invasion als geschosse
einschlagen
mörserbeschuss ganz in der nähe
lasst uns lieber in deckung
immer wieder neue einschläge laut hörbar
die soldaten geben jetzt das zeichen
schnellschuss erzieher mit der
einheimischen soldaten
also durch die gräben hindurch ab in den
nächsten bunker
gerade eben hat es hier direkt an
unserer position nur wenige hundert
meter entfernt einstiege gegeben und wir
mussten dann mit den ukrainischen
soldaten hier in untergrund sozusagen in
ihr versteck um uns vor weiteren
möglichen attacken von pro russischer
seite zu schützen das was wir hier
erleben gerade in diesem moment passiert
hier jeden tag und jede nacht und die
ukrainische soldaten wissen nie wann
gegen sie geschossen wird waren sie
angegriffen werden nach einigen minuten
etwas durchatmen paul ronzheimer fragt
andré der mit seinen 23 jahren für die
ukraine kämpft ob ihm die tausenden
russischen panzer diese riesige armee
denn gar keine angst macht
keine sorge wir haben panzer und gute
ausrüstung aber wir werden die hier
stoppen wir haben keine angst
und weiter durch die ost ukraine mit dem
schaukelnden auto vorbei an häusern mit
frischen kriegs spuren dieses jahr nach
einem granatenanschlag zerstört
notdürftig wird jetzt das loch gestopft
im eiskalten binden
und wieder geht es an der front entlang
dort wo immer beschuss droht auch hier
leben menschen kinder
paul ronzheimer trifft katja vierfache
mama warum gehen sie nicht weg sie haben
doch vier kinder ich kann doch nirgendwo
anders hin nirgendwo wartet jemand auch
nicht und glauben sie dass putin sich
längst zum krieg entschieden hat fragt
paul ronzheimer
klar das hat er schon lange entschieden
wir haben gerade mit jemandem auf der
russischen seite gesprochen die haben
jetzt die generalmobilmachung verkündet
und alle frauen und kinder müssen raus
und die warten jetzt gerade in bussen an
der russischen grenze die sind geschockt
das sind beeindruckende stimme
beeindruckte bilder die uns da heute
mitgebracht hast am heutigen tag aus dem
auszug keine wie weit bist du aktuell
entfernt von den atelier stellungen der
russen
ich bin in constantin auf keiner stadt
in der region donetsk man weiß
mittlerweile donets ist die stadt die
2014 eingenommen wurde von russen und
von separatisten gemeinsam muss man
sagen wir sind wenige kilometer hier von
dieser front entfernt und das
gefährliche an dieser front ist dass sie
eben durch dörfer geht und da sind viele
zivilisten die nicht weggehen wollen
weil sie nicht wissen wohin sie sollen
und man hört hier den ganzen tag und
auch gestern nach die ganze zeit
einschläge so viele einschläge wie es
zuletzt
2015/2016 gegeben hat täuscht der
eindruck oder reich der moment ein
funken um eben ein ganzes feuer zu
entfachen
das ist das was putin ganz
offensichtlich will das ist auch das was
uns ukrainische soldaten sagen sie sagen
dass man sie bewusst provozieren will
also dass man von russischer seite
ukrainische stellung angreift um eine
reaktion zu provozieren und dann sagen
zu können die ukraine haben uns
angegriffen und jetzt brauchen wir die
gesamte russische armee das ist das was
man glaubt was hier passieren könnte das
ist das was auch der präsident bruno
risi lenz geht zu mir gesagt hat in
dieser woche dass man deshalb ruhe
bewahren muss dass man nicht panisch
sein darf und dass vor allem die
ukrainischen soldaten die fassung
bewahren müssen nur was die bilder
gerade gesehen was gesehen wie wir dort
heute morgen waren das ist natürlich
sehr sehr schwierig wenn man angegriffen
wird herr kornblum jetzt sagt paul
ronzheimer muster ruhe bewahren auf
keinen fall in panik geraten
gleichzeitig habe mir gerade in der
runde schon über eine klare botschaft an
putin gesprochen warum nach all den
wochen gibt es bisher keine klare
botschaft erkrankung wie erklären sie
das
naja ich glaube es gibt mindestens aus
den vereinigten staaten gibt es eine
sehr klare botschaft
und puten weiß ganz genau woran er ist
er weiß aber auch welche kalkulationen
der macht und für ihn ist
mindestens das gefühl von bedrohung
nicht nur in ukraine sondern auch im
westen wahrscheinlich ein wichtiges ziel
ich glaube wir müssen ein bisschen ruhe
bewahren nicht
unbedingt der
debatte mit putin sondern unter uns
selbst warum es sich hier handelt es
handelt sich nicht um die erweiterung
von nato es handelt sich nicht um eine
bedrohung für russland sondern es
handelt sich um genau die entwicklung
wofür die eu gegründet worden ist das
heißt die ausweitung der demokratie in
allen richtungen in europe und putin hat
angst nicht unbedingt vor deutschen oder
amerikanischen oder ukrainischen
streitkräfte soll er hat angst vor der
demokratie
und wenn wir das verstehen und wir
verstehen wie wichtig ist es dass du
keine auch zu uns als demokratisches
land aufnehmen hingehört dann werden wir
auch natürlich die ziele und auch die
taktik für diese konfrontation besser
verstehen im moment herrscht putin die
in debatte muss man sagen muss man ganz
ehrlich sagen mittel zeit mindestens
acht jahren an ein argument das sagt der
westen bedroht ihn russland muss sich
beteiligen
das könnte nicht anders sein der westen
bedroht ihn nun dadurch dass der westen
offen und frei ist und dass ukraine auch
einen teil der freien westen sein will
das ist aber unser ziel und das ist
keine bedrohung und das soll auch keine
für russland überhaupt kein problem
bilden aber punkte will die keine
demokratie er will keine offenheit der
keine freiheit und deshalb ist die
ukraine für ihn tatsächlich eine
mindestens politische und psychologische
bedrohung die demokratie ist die
bedrohung für wladimir putin herr
mählich warum es ist der eu warum es uns
auch in deutschland offenbar ja nicht
ausreichend gelungen putin abzuschrecken
sowie das in der zeit des kalten krieges
war dass man sich da eben ja als feinde
gegenüber stand aber offenbar
ist diese abschreckung bisher nicht
gelungen gegenüber putin warum
eine gute frage dass das was wir heute
haben wir haben zumindest also die
breite einigkeit innerhalb der eu auch
des westlichen blogs aber auf der
anderen seite fällt es eben an diese
abschreckung es fehlt an sehr sehr
robusten präventiven strafmaßnahmen
gegenüber russland und darum geht es
heute wir müssen jetzt endlich handeln
und wenn wir hören von den
amerikanischen freunden dass dieser
angriff schon wie möglich in den
nächsten tagen beginnen sollte dann dann
sollte man schon eigentlich oder hätte
man schon gestern oder vorgestern dieser
präventiven strafmaßnahmen herr
botschafter kornblum hatte diese auch
genannte sowie herr weber das heißt wir
müssten ähnliche morgen spätestens es
gibt ein radler in brüssel der eu
aussenminister minister wird morgen auch
dabei sein und berichten über die lage
und das ist vielleicht die letzte chance
der diplomatie mit
einigen maßnahmen die sofort eingeführt
werden müssen gegen russland und dann
schrift aber schrittweise schauen also
wenn es keine wirkung erzeugt dann
müssen die weiteren maßnahmen folgen das
ist die logik die die auch herr putin
verstehen wird alles andere wird nur als
eine beschwichtigungspolitik als apis
mente verstehen das hat gestern auch
mein präsident in münchen hier ganz klar
gesagt sie sind dafür herr melnik sie
sind ebenfalls dafür dass jetzt auf den
tisch zu legen hardcore um sie fordern
dass herr weber und sie stehen dem
moment entgegen herr stegner und der
bundeskanzler olaf scholz warum müsste
man nicht ganz klar benennen die antwort
noch nicht angekommen ist bei wladimir
putin das sind diese aktion und die
greifen jetzt
zum einen möchte ich kann man darauf
hinweisen dass das was er gesagt hat im
widerspruch zu dem steht was seine
eigene partei vorsitzende herr söder sei
großer märz 8 also eigentlich sind die
konservativen offenbar auch nicht ich
glaube ich bin ich gerade sagen der auch
im westen magisch der ganz kurzen sofort
zu ihnen zurück nur dass sie gerade hand
genommen haben da sind dass mich ganz
schwierig wird wenn wie hier bei herrn
merz und händler sprechen hier geht es
um wirklich früher haben wir immer
zitiert und ich darf wieder sprechen
weil ich wahrgenommen habe was ändern
was wenn wir jetzt öffentlich gesagt das
ist ein widerspruch zu dem was er weiß
aber auch unbeschadet dessen gibt es
eine klare botschaft ich glaube nicht
dass es darum geht interview kriege zu
führen sondern dass es darum geht die
glasklare botschaft zu geben die hat es
in allen gesprächen gegeben und ich lage
selbst zu eskalieren indem man sozusagen
vorhersagt wenn das passiert passiert
genau dieses öffentlich das ist nicht
besonders klug abschreckung funktioniert
er dadurch dass der gegner auch ein
stück im ungewissen gelassen wird und
man nicht öffentlich darlegen und
schritt eins zwei oder drei passiert
sondern dass man sehr deutlich macht
welche konsequenzen es haben alle
gemacht französischer präsident der
deutsche bundeskanzler der britische
premier der amerikanische präsident in
allen gesprächen ist das klipp und klar
gesagt worden wir wissen nicht was
passiert was wir aber wissen ist das ist
eine militärische auseinandersetzung in
europa kann loszufahren für die
zivilbevölkerung und es hätte keine
gewinner gehen deswegen muss alles
unternommen werden diplomatischen was zu
verhindern genau das tun wir einigkeit
in der sache und klarheit dass man das
in der diplomatie versucht das finde ich
sehr viel schlauer als ich öffentlich
den kritikern wenn ich ihnen an einem
punkt widersprechen darf weil sie vorhin
gesagt habe früher hatte man sich als
feinde gegenüber gestanden die strecke
hätte funktioniert das ziel kann nicht
sein sich als feinde gegenüber zu stehen
das kann nicht unser ziel sein sondern
wir brauchen eine sicherheit die ganz in
europa nur geben als gemeinsame
sicherheit auch mit russen naja das ist
ziemlich egal möglicherweise auch dass
unser ziel ist wenn da zehntausende
hunderttausende soldaten direkt an der
grenze stehen und eben eine bedrohung
eine zunehmende bedrohung darstellen für
die ukraine dann fällt einem das wort
freund erstmal nicht so richtig ein herr
stegner sind sie denn überzeugt davon
dass olaf scholz hinter den kulissen
ganz klar die karten auf den tisch
gelegt hat denn der 1 entsteht ja nicht
man sagt nur nicht was dann genau
passiert also man benennt nicht ganz
klar die szenarien sondern man weiß auch
gar nicht ganz genau was da passiert
weil man sich in europa nämlich gar
nicht hundertprozentig einig ist weil
sie nämlich vor allen dingen bremsen und
sich eben nicht klar bekennen dann ist
es doch eine überraschung sie das ist
eine behauptung dann stimmt doch nichts
ist sie ist alles ist auf dem tisch ja
da kann schon passieren hat klipp und
klar gesagt es ist ja keinerlei
unterschiede mit der bundesregierung
gehe und dass die behaupten die er
aufgestellt werden wir sein da nicht
eigentlich falsch sind ich glaube nur
dass der unterschied vielleicht darin
besteht dass wir der meinung sind dass
die einzige möglichkeit die diplomatie
ist wir hatten weder waffenlieferungen
noch davon die sachen selbst zu
eskalieren sondern es muss haben
diplomatie gehen militärisch kann der
konflikt nicht gelöst sein und darf er
nicht gelöst werden das muss mit aller
macht versucht werden und da muss da wer
ist eigentlich sei nach allem was ich
weiß ist er das ich kenne keine andere
informationen hat die hohe weber an
informationen kennt alles was wir hören
ist dass es bei allen gesprächen der
verbündeten einigkeit gibt und
deutschland ist teil davon amerikanische
präsident das ausdrücklich an die
adresse deutschlands gesagt und sie
haben darüber im bundestag debattiert am
freitag es gibt da keine unterschiede
nur ich sag nochmal öffentlich sich
radikal zu äußern nützt gar nichts ist
mein eindruck weder herrn putin hat das
irgendeinen sinn un sanktionen in kraft
zu setzen
bevor es so zu sagen was militärisch
passiert ist hat davon halte ich ehrlich
gesagt auch nichts im übrigen will ich
mal sagen die lage in der ukraine ist
schon seit jahren probleme und der
minsker vertrag von beiden seiten leider
nicht eingehalten